[Music]
good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight after weeks of hype and
innuendo and threats and a lot of
hysterics we finally have the House
Intelligence Committee memo in hand
tonight we're gonna spend the next hour
telling you about it what's in it what
it means what it tells us about how our
leaders govern when we're not watching
them if you're a regular viewer you know
we rarely spend an entire show on a
single topic we think this is worth it
there's been so much lying about this
memo by partisans in Congress and hyenas
in the press that it's lessons are at
risk of being drowned out and lost we
think truth is the antidote to that so
to begin with what does the memo
actually say well as it turns out it's
not primarily about Donald Trump or even
about the broader Russia investigation
the memo is really the story of a semi
obscure Trump campaign volunteer called
Carter page back in 2016 was identified
by the Obama administration as a secret
agent of the Putin government four times
FBI officials went to a federal
surveillance court and argued they had
probable cause to believe that Carter
page was working with Russian spies he
was an agent of a foreign government
three times FBI director Jim Comey
personally signed off on this claim
deputy director Andrew McCabe and Deputy
Attorney General rod Rosenstein put
their names to it as well so why were
all of these officials so certain that
Paige who was a Naval Academy graduate
who has no criminal record was betraying
his country because we now know they
were lying on the Trump dossier
that's the still unverified opposition
research dump paid for by the RNC in the
Hillary campaign and compiled by a
British spy called Christopher steel the
Trump dossier made spying on Carter page
possible how are we sure of that because
Andrew McCabe of the FBI said so behind
closed doors under oath to Congress just
this past December now Democrats are now
furiously denying that in anonymous
leaks to sympathetic reporters but it's
obviously true in a minute we'll talk to
a member of Congress who was in the room
when McCabe said it but ask yourself if
the FBI had power
additional evidence that page was a
Russian spy why did they include the
dossier in their request at all indeed
why did they lead with it the Trump
dossier allowed our government to spy on
Carter page that is not a talking point
it is a fact and given that it's a fact
it is remarkable to learn that the FBI
knew at the time that the dossier was
unreliable to put it Gerald charitably
an independent FBI unit analyzed that
document and found its claims quote only
minimally corroborated the FBI also knew
that the dossiers author Christopher
Steele was an inflamed partisan working
on behalf of political operatives trying
to win a presidential race you'll
remember Steele actually told DOJ
employee Bruce or that he was quote
desperate that Donald Trump not get
elected and was passionate about him not
being president so assessing all of this
no rational person could in good faith
treat the Trump dossier as fact and yet
that is exactly how the FBI presented it
to the FISA Court when they asked to spy
on Carter page that effort mentioned any
of the facts we just gave you they hid
them that is lying there is no other way
to describe it they've been busted lying
but they won't admit it
former FBI director Jim Comey took to
Twitter today not to apologize for any
of this or even to address the facts the
memo raised but to mock the release of
the memo like the aspiring MSNBC
contributor he apparently is dishonest
and misleading he said he didn't bother
to explain how it was dishonest and
misleading of course he didn't call me
who leaked his notes on private meetings
with the president in a petty revenge
move after being fired he is now
declaring it beyond the pale somehow for
Congress to carry out its constitutional
duties of oversight of the FBI Comey
apparently used the FBI as a fourth
co-equal branch of government not
subject to the authority of the other
three suddenly a lot of people in
Washington seem to agree with him the
current FBI director for example the one
that Trump chose Christopher Rea
apparently argued that the names of FBI
officials in the memo ought to be
redacted hidden from public view why how
exactly would that serve the public
interest it would not serve the public
interest it would protect the FBI and as
always that was the point all of this
should make you nervous the dishonesty
mixed with self-righteousness looking
back you wonder how many people at the
FBI ever even believed just for a moment
even the Carter page was actually a
Russian agent they clearly don't believe
that now if they did Paige would be in
handcuffs yet he's still a free man
there was civil liberties have been
violated and his reputation has been
destroyed Democrats could not care less
they're still pretending that somehow
Carter Paige hurt this country they know
that's a lie
but Paige himself for what happens to
him in the future is all irrelevant to
them if he can be used to destroy a
president they hate they are happy to
use him even if he is crushed in the
process and that may be the real lesson
of this memo and it's the reason we're
spending an hour on it tonight ten years
from now Donald Trump will be gone the
Democrats will have forgotten that they
once pretended to fear Russia as a
threat to our democracy or whatever but
our law enforcement and intelligence
agencies will remain as long as this
country stays intact and we have got to
trust them
we give them incredible powers awesome
powers including the power to take human
life the most basic of all we allow them
by the way to operate in secrecy because
they tell us they must in exchange for
all of that we ask them to operate with
integrity to prove to us that they
haven't become tools of a political
regime because always in everywhere
that is the temptation and unfortunately
it looks like it just happened here